The Joe Rogan Experience it's a
wonderful thing that I had to fight to
you know get everybody approval well
It's tricky in boxing sometimes because
sometimes it's difficult to make those
match-ups happen in a dream match up
like that between two undefeated world
champions and for you to dominate the
way you did because a lot of people had
that like a pick em fight like a lot of
people didn't know how to call it but
you just [__] ran that fight you ran
that fight that was amazing yeah you
know that's a fight that we've been
wanting for years
and um to finally secure the fight and
perform the way that I performed it was
it was a great moment for me and my
career it was beautiful man I mean the
just the way you control the way you
switch things up the way you controlled
the pace of the fight the defense your
defense was on point those hooks that
you were Landing in close were
magnificent it was a brilliant fight man
I mean I'm sure you appreciate it I'm
sure you watched it a bunch of times but
man that was like a real because it was
such a mainstream fight such a huge
fight where everybody was paying
attention to it and talking about it
even casuals that they got to see you
perform that way and you know now it's
like there's no dispute you're the
number one pound for pound guy on Earth
yeah uh that's something that I got a
credit to my coaches you know because we
drilled
everything that you've seen
fight night we drilled it time and time
again time and time again so it was it
was
it came natural and easy for me when the
when the fight came
you know like I said only thing they
kept saying
uh how he's gonna beat me is because
he's bigger and he's stronger that was
it you look stronger of course of course
and I was just like how do you know he's
stronger than me right he might be
bigger than me but big don't mean
stronger but he's just taller than you
you look more muscular than him too but
it was just the the technique was what
really stood out it's like you just were
a master in there it was a master class
that's something that they wasn't giving
me credit for as well how because they
said I think it's like how are they not
you know I don't know what it is
um
with me they just always try to diminish
my my accomplishments and oh well who I
was fighting they say oh well you wasn't
fighting nobody and this guy aerospence
is the most uh fundamental Lee sound
fighter in the game so
um
that's why everybody was picking them
but I was favored in Vegas so Vegas must
have had it right yeah well the wise
people picked you as a favorite you know
just just based on your accomplishments
it's not like Errol Spence wasn't a
great fighter he's a great fighter but
it's so interesting when you watch a
great fighter against what I believe is
an all-time great it's just that there's
just levels upon levels upon levels upon
levels
and right now you're at the top of the
[__] Mountain yes yes yes and I and
I'm I'm enjoying it I'm enjoying it
beautiful you deserve it you deserve it
that's uh when when you plan for that
fight you knew that you were probably
gonna fight him like for the last few
years it was something that was on the
table but not really uh there was a
point there was a point in time where I
was like you know uh I shifted gears and
I shifted my mind off at Aerosmith
because
um I didn't feel like the fight was
going to happen but once
uh left Top Rank and we started
negotiating I was like oh well maybe
this fight will happen and then once I
fought avanesian because
the conversations
and everything that we was talking about
to get the fight done it wasn't lining
up to what I wanted so I decided to take
another fight and I came back to the
table and like Hey listen
let's get this fight made and uh at that
point in time things wasn't gone
how I would have liked it to go so I
just hit up Spence like hey man listen
man
if if me and you gonna fight me and
you're gonna get this done because you
know there's a lot of people that
blocking the fight how are they blocking
like what was the what was the whole
which is business-wise you know I just
felt like I was worth x amount and they
felt like I wasn't and uh they wanted to
do the deal a certain way and I wanted
to do a deal the fair way and
um Aerospace seen it he was just he was
he was agreeing with everything that I
said it was like yeah we can do this we
can do that
and he probably felt like he gave up too
much you know at the at the end when it
was all said and done but I was I felt
like everything was fair
was it in terms of like the purse split
everything everything we talked about
everything yeah and so
this fight had been discussed for like
how many years now at least five five
years wow that's crazy that it takes
that long for something like this to
happen in boxing when I came when I came
uh to the welterweight Division I called
out all the Champions except Sean Porter
I called out all the Champions I went at
the mall you know at that time and I
wasn't able to get in the ring with any
of them and at that point in time they
was calling Aerosmith's The Boogeyman
and
my reply was how is he the boogeyman
when I'm chasing him
you know um
I just wanted to prove to the world that
that I was better than what they said I
was because
given the fact that
how great I looked against each opponent
they say oh well
he wasn't nothing or he was this he he
was that because how talented I am right
so they didn't want to give me no credit
because I passed all my tests with
flying colors so yeah it was great to
get in a ring with Errol Spence Jr and
do the same thing if not better than I
did for the past opponents that I faced
no you were on fire it was it's sort of
the same thing that Roy Jones Jr faced
like everybody's like Roy hasn't beaten
anybody like yes he has it's just he's
so much better than everybody else that
he was making everybody else look like
there weren't any good but those were
World Championship caliber Fighters and
Roy was just lighting them up right
that's that sometimes when a fighter
eclipses everyone else and reaches the
Pinnacle that's the criticism they face
until there's an undeniable moment you
know and that was that was your
undeniable moment like everybody's got
to shut the [__] up yeah yeah and that's
and that's what you know uh
my feelings was
you know a lot of people like man you
didn't look too happy you know after
after you won after you won I didn't see
the excitement in you I was like man I
was happy I was happy just I had to
prove myself you know to the world how
great I knew I was but at the same time
I was kind of disappointed at the same
time that it took this long
for me to get my recognition for me to
get a big Marquee fight
of this status at 35 years old yeah
especially after Chasing it for five
years right and I was chasing Manny
Pacquiao for probably five years
probably before yeah so it's like I'm
being championed for nine years going on
10 years in March so I've been doing
this game for a long time
you know and uh I've been at top since
since I've been Gamboa and I've been
looking for all the biggest challenges
there is and
some of them I was able to to capture
and some of them went the other way
and I'm just blessed to be able to be
the first man to be Undisputed in the
junior welterweight division the first
man to be Undisputed in a welterweight
division in a Four Bell era the first
man to be Undisputed in two-way
divisions so uh it's a blessing it's a
blessing it's a huge blessing it's it's
an amazing accomplishment you looked
happy you were dancing with your mom you
were having a good time yeah I don't
know why people thought you weren't
happy because you know when you when you
go in the back room everybody want to
see the excitement right I was just like
was there anything unusual about that
fight like is that exactly how you
expected the exchanges to go I'm sure
you watched a ton of tape on him right
actually I didn't really I didn't
because a lot of people always ask me do
I watch a lot of film on my opponents
and I always tell them no because I have
a different style they're not going to
fight me the same style or the same way
that they thought their previous
opponents they just not you know so I
already knew how he fought I just
watched probably like two fights of his
just to get a feel for what he liked to
do what he don't like the things that
you know I can capitalize on
and that's it like I don't watch too
much film because I'm gonna make my
adjustments on the Fly inside the ring
so yeah I don't watch too much film
that's interesting what is the the
general consensus on that about watching
film do most Champions watch film is it
is it just on an individual basis no
some people like to watch film to where
they feel as if they know
uh what their opponent is going to do
when they're gonna do it because they
got certain habits to uh identify uh
when they're going to throw a punch or
or when they want to back up certain
things that you you see as a as a top
athlete you start noticing okay I
noticed that he's doing this when he's
doing this he's doing that when he's
doing this and uh you pick up on that
and so you you put it in your in your
mind like okay we're gonna prepare for
this when you do that we're gonna do
this so you try to capitalize on it but
me
I never was that type of person I let my
coaches they do the uh studying and then
they come up with a plan and then they
shoot me the plan the plan to win and we
just go from there
when you switch because you're you're in
my opinion the best ever at switching
from Orthodox to South Boston since
Marvin Hagler you're the best ever like
when you just when do you decide do you
just feel it do you go out there of
Southpaw sometimes and say I'm gonna
[__] switch it up like how do you how
do you make those those changes well
I think I made the change
to fight southpaw
uh in the back dress room really yeah
because I was like man how should I come
out
because in my mind I was just so filled
with like the energy from
the weigh-ins the press conference the
way the the the moment so I was like man
I just want to go out there and you know
everybody's saying I'm too small so I
wanted to prove it wrong everybody was
saying he's gonna walk me down so I was
just like man you know they just don't
know like I just had that chip on my
shoulder like I just want to go go head
on with the bull and just go fight him
and it was like just box
I was like just bugs and then I was
remembering I was like he ever fought
too many southpaws before
and then on one of the occasions he got
hurt real bad by a hook
so I was like I'm coming out South Park
and I'm and we going box just to start
off but at the same time
I'm gonna get my respect out the gate
I'm not going to be doing all that
moving so the plan was never to move and
everybody
when you interview them they was like oh
Terrence got to be uh
slippery he can't stand in front of
spins he can't do this he got to get on
his bicycle I'm like
ain't no Terminator I'm like man I'm
gonna be right there in front of him
like I always do you know I'm gonna make
a Miss I make them pay and I'm gonna
fight my my fight so
I feel like that was the key for uh the
victory because he wasn't used to
fighting southpaws do you feel as
comfortable Orthodox as South Park is
there do you feel like you're better in
one stance or is it just depending upon
the opponent I think it's dependent on
the opponent you know uh I feel I'm
equally as uh great in both stands I'm
very powerful in both stands
I hit
just as hard with my left probably even
harder with my left am I right you know
but uh I think it's the opponent
they were talking about it in the
broadcast they said that when you were a
kid you hurt your hand and so that's why
you started practicing Southpaw yeah
that's when I started actually
practicing it you know uh
that was something that when I when I
had the cast on I was like man I love
the gym so much I'm like man I'm not
leaving the gym like I'm going practice
with this left and that's when I got the
left stronger because at first when I go
softball it was only you know my righty
my right my right then when my hand got
messed up
start working on the left and start
getting stronger and stronger and I
start getting more accurate because at
first just throw it just to be throwing
it and then you know it just got to a
point where they both my left was
actually way stronger than my right
when it came back so I had to get my
right back stronger
that's great it's crazy that you have
that option because that's such an
amazing advantage to be able to fight
just as comfortably from Orthodox of
South Park oh yeah definitely definitely
you know um I look at it like you can't
go nowhere right like you trapped like
you move to your left I can go Southpaw
and cut you off you move to your right I
can go Orthodox and cut you off so and
then it and then it it's great that I
can pack a punch in both hands as well
because a lot of people when they switch
they give up something I think when I
switch I gain something in both stands
that I probably
don't have in the other stands so
it's great for me